and you brought us now to the end of
this particular proceeding
they will say it is more time than any
time in history
but we will say that history has been
long
underserving its citizens and we
humbly thank you for giving this family
the strength to stand
where other families didn't even get a
court date
we remember eric garner today yes we
remember
michael brown yes we remember jacob
blake
yeah who are still with us we remember
tamir rice on his birthday
19 years old would have been today we
remember brianna taylor
they never got a court date we did get a
court date of conviction
and some time amen some will say that's
progress
i will say as malcolm x said if you have
a
knife in my back six inches to take out
four inches is progress
but i still have two inches of knife in
my back
the knife is still in our back as long
as these
unresolved cases are there
and those of us in the civil rights
community
this community will not stop until
justice becomes a matter of generalism
children
so
so
so
that we need all of you we need the
media
we need the activists because the second
we turn around and leave
we have to go back and ask ourselves how
do we get
more justice for george floyd how do we
get justice for dante right
how do we get justice for winston smith
how do we get justice for the many
families here
who are regularly fought for on behalf
by people like tashira garaway and her
group
nakima levy armstrong and her group and
without all of you
we don't have the energy for that fight
right here
we need you all to keep turning out and
we appreciate it
because it's allowed the floyd family to
get the most historic justice we've ever
seen
but it's not enough amen thank you not
enough don't forget
and as we get ready to bring up the
floyd family
i would be remiss if brandon as we heard
the sentence uh leaned in and whispered
in my ear
i got a text from brianna
taylor's mother congratulating us on
getting some justice
the justice that she never got and i
have to tell you reverend alas
derek shelby's mother was standing up
there
making her comments i thought of tamika
palmer
brianna taylor's mother and so it's not
enough until
we get justice for all of our
people who have been killed unjustly
i i think
yeah brianna taylor is with us uh
right now we're to have you hear from
some of the floyd family members
uh you've come to know him
he has been speaking at the u.s congress
to united nations and everywhere saying
that
we demand justice for my big brother
george floyd
he sounds like a politician rather now
uh
mr filoni's floyd
uh i got a a lot of emotions
going through my head right now but uh i
just find it uh
profound that i felt that
i beg for justice for my brother
some type of accountability the
treatment that
i thought that everybody should receive
is just life you know
you can't get that back we all live
together
in this world and we all want to be able
to work together in this world
you have good police officers and you
have bad ones the fact that you
shouldn't have to sort them out
the community that i grew up in it was a
lot of african-american people
but the fact that minnesota has
a greater amount of caucasian people i
still think that everybody should be the
same
everybody should be neutral everybody
should want to make a difference and
make sure
that people when they come to minnesota
they don't think
about george floyd they should be able
to think about
how great minnesota is not thinking
about
philando castile you know his mother is
still
fighting yes thinking about dante
wright many families i had to console
you think about anthony mclean
he was killed all these people were shot
in the back most of them the fact that
i'm here and i'm still standing and over
a year later
i'm still speaking and i'm speaking out
times are hard i have a family we wake
up every day
and we don't see my brother emphasis
all around the house he would have been
in
the fact that gianna would grow up
knowing that
her father had made a difference in the
world
but the fact that she cannot have a
sweet 16.
she cannot have him walk her down at all
she would not be able to have prom with
the daddy dance
this is not something realistic
this is something is like a dream but we
all
need to stand up for what is right all
right
all these activists and all these
advocates i thank you all
definitely i thank you all because if
you all didn't speak out
we wouldn't have had a lot of help but
the fact that the world
you got to think about japan you have to
think about germany
you have to thank united nations you
have to think
uh italy i have so many different people
i spoke to
africa all around the world and they all
think the same way
your skin color should not define who
you are
it should never be a weapon and the fact
that
we're here standing today still
breathing
we're still fighting reverend always
said keep fighting
and that's something i can't stop i want
to tell miss carl
i love you yeah i know it's hard that's
erigona's mom i want to tell brianna
taylor mom i love you
pamela i know it's hard i want to tell
pamela turner that's beethoven texas
yeah
this is this is not okay what daughter
is walking around
and i know she's in tears every day
thinking about her mother
her mother was killed in point blank
range shot multiple times
so many different people all around the
world who didn't even have this
type of technology i just want to
reiterate
not just black lives matter all lives
matter
we need to stand up and fight can't get
comfortable
because when you get comfortable people
forget about you
amen so the legend will still live on
george is not here but his spirit lives
here brianna taylor is not here but the
spirit still lives here
eric garner is not here spirit's still
right here
but the fact that we're here fighting i
want all you all to stand up and fight
thank you all so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and next we're going to have another
brother of george
who came all the way from new york
brooklyn new york
and as we're going to do some it's not
lost on us as uh
attorney steward and attorney roman
nucha and i talked
it's always a journey to justice tony
told me
laquan mcdonough who was found geared
his killer the police officer that
killed him shot him 14 times in the back
on video 16 times in the back
on video and he was convicted of
second-degree murder
and he was only sentenced to six years
botham jones who in dallas texas
was killed in his own apartment right
the
white policewoman amber geiger was found
guilty of first-degree murder reverend
alex
and she was only sentenced to 10 years
and justin miller what was it uh
walter scott in south carolina
same conviction shot in the back on
video
convicted 20 years so
each step each case
we keep making progress we came too
far to stop now we have to
keep going forward and so that's why all
the energy we have in this courtroom
we have to take the capitol hill and we
have to
join senator cory booker we have to join
congresswoman
karen bass senator tim scott we got to
say
you all we need meaningful police reform
so we don't have to put up with these
injustices seem like reverend now every
other week
there's a new hashtag we can stop this
america
we're at the turning point terrence
floyd
brooklyn new york
let me hear y'all say change let me hear
y'all say
change that's right
just like i heard y'all say change all
together that's how we gonna keep the
change going
together fight keep fighting the way we
got here
is because of our fight and your fight
together y'all hit the streets
be thankful for y'all and and we just we
just
i'm overwhelmed i'm overwhelmed because
i'm gonna tell you a quick story
i had a dream other night i was um
in a field i was in a field in in the
south i went out with my family
and i saw i looked back and i saw a man
i saw a man coming up walking walking
and i'm trying to figure out who is that
who is that
i look i look he gets closer and all of
a sudden i see the hat [ __ ] to the side
like this
anybody that know me know who that is
that's my father
so he got close to me and he gave me a
smile
and he gave me a hug i woke up that
dream was so real
i woke up hugging myself so i knew
i was a little leery about about the
citizen but because of that
i knew that my father was saying
you good he's good
keep doing what you're doing for me
for your brother for your name
because we floyd strong and we're going
to stay strong
thank you terrence uh next we will hear
from
uh the nephew of george floyd who's like
a brother uh
like a son in many regards to him
brandon williams
it's funny that we got
justice but not enough justice
you know i remember standing here the
first day of trial in this very same
spot
and we were very optimistic and unsure
of what was going to happen
after seeing that video we should have
been 100 sure
that we will be at a guilty conviction
with a maximum sentence
when you think about george being
murdered
and cold blood with a knee on his nick
for nine minutes and 29 seconds
execution style and broad day like 22
and a half years is not enough
right all right we will serve the life
sentence
we can't get george back gianna can't
hug george again
he'll be able to hug his family possibly
and see his family again
we can't get george back so in
retrospect
i feel that he should have received the
life sentence as well
what kind of message are you sending to
our country what kind of message are you
sending to
the younger kids like gianna that you
can kill a man
in cold blood and get a slap on the
wrist that's like a slap in the face to
all of us standing up here
and everybody around the world who feel
what we feel and saw that video
so i won't celebrate this i won't
celebrate it at all
but i will celebrate a guilty conviction
on a police officer that killed the
black man
because far too many times we see them
kill us and get right away with it
i will celebrate this as a victory
for miss tamika palmer who i'm very very
close with
i hope that attorney daniel cameron out
of kentucky can follow keith edison's
lead
and charge the cops who killed brianna
taylor yeah
so there are some positive things to
take from this but this 22 and a half
years just isn't one for me
thank you all right all right brandon
thank you from the heart brandon uh
and we have his brother his baby brother
rodney floyd from houston texas third
ward
hey how y'all doing you know i would
like to
thank the protesters first the local
protesters
and uh in this city i'd like to thank
all the protesters that came out across
the country to this city
and standing up in their cities as well
demanding
change we all have one thing in common
we won't change for my brother's case
this right here is this 22 year sentence
they gave this man
it's a slap on the wrist we serving a
life sentence to not having them in our
life
and that hurts me to death and looking
at his daughter beautiful daughter
gianna in her video
saying the first video my dad changed
the world
he did change the world but at the end
result
he gets a slap on her wrist but nephew
just said
22 years from killing her dad that she
can't
take her to school he can't eat lunch
with her he can't conversate with her i
know with my daughter i love
my daughter hugs we talk that's my
little best friend
and i hate to see that he cannot have
that she can't have that connection
with her father those great
conversations those wonderful phone
calls
lighting up her face you know
and around the world black white brown
we all need to come together take our
bus to the senate
stand out there and demand these jaws
flowing act be passed
and also as well as the x being past
past
we need to stand up put pressure on this
senate right you know
and i what i was thinking last night
guys honestly
we hear obama say this plenty of times
get out and vote we hear
so many folks that get out of vote
everybody got out voted most in these
streets and we got changed we got
our first black president a lot of
people came together like they did now
my brother's death and we got this
but guess what people we need to take
that same energy bring that back to the
senate
and demand them pass that bill because
as we've seen we've seen trump numerous
times stand up
first fussing on camera numerous times
countless times because
he did not have the power that we
thought he had to get something done
he had to call on the senate and we need
to get out there understand that message
go to the senate put press on the senate
and get these bills and laws passed for
all of us
to stand on this american flag as one
and we
as black people need to know this
american fact represents us that we
feel it though all right
thank you rodney and as we uh bring his
cousin sharita
yeah please understand this is only
one step in getting accountability
in the criminal level the federal
charges are still pending
so i do believe that when polonius and
terence and
rodney saved the maximum it is still
attainable
to get maximum accountability
for george floyd maximum
accountability for george floyd
maximum accountability for george floyd
maximum accountability for george floyd
maximum accountability for george barr
maximum accountability for george floyd
maximum accountability for george floyd
now you will hear from his cousin
cherita tate
hello everybody uh i won't spend a whole
lot of time
sort of reiterating what my family has
already said i think they have spoke
very eloquently
about how we dealt with this last year
and our thought processes
as it relates to the amount of time that
derek shelvin was given
truth be told um i don't think any
sentence would be enough because what
truly
would be justice for would be for us to
be able to have george back
but with that being said i'd just like
to take this time to thank the countless
number of people that have been
supportive of us since the very
beginning
i remember when we uh first came here
and we were
talking about you know the sentence and
and
the trial and what we potentially the
outcome would be
and as we sat through the trial and
watched the murder
over and over again and came back with
the three convictions
then we uh all waited and waited for
this day
i will have to say that um we didn't get
what we wanted
we definitely wanted to see the maximum
penalty but however as they've already
stated we do have the federal
ahead of us and we are hoping that we
can uh
get some real accountability with him
getting a life sentence
and lastly i just want to speak on the
the policing act
you know we've had it partially it's
before the senate
and i would just say what echo what
everyone else has said we need this past
immediately
we need to really have some true
accountability across the board
thank you and finally before we
uh take a few of your questions we have
his cousin tara brown
from houston texas
i just want to say um you know my family
has spoken a lot about uh
everything that we we've gone through
since we started this journey
um and i will tell you it definitely has
been
a journey for us and as a family
we decided that we were committed to two
things
for sure we wanted to make sure that we
got
some measure of justice for for george
and for the countless other families who
have lost
loved ones in the way that we did
and the other thing is that we were
committed to making sure that we
force the change that we want to see and
creates legacy
that will live on forever just want to
say thank you to everybody who has
supported us
throughout this journey especially the
protesters and the activists who have
been
non-stop and relentless and and they've
helped us get to this point
and the other thing is we want to say
that this bill needs to get passed
and i want to make sure that we don't
stop
just with this bill but it's important
that you hold your state
elected officials accountable to that as
well
we are also looking at the local level
where they're making change even in our
city where we're from in houston
there has been um some changes already
our our mayor sylvester turner has
you know banned choke hold and and you
know we have
um qualified qualified immunity is on
the table
so we are keeping active and we want to
make sure that you stay in the fight
please keep fighting thank you thank you
and finally our national leader reverend
al
sharpton we're going to open up the
questions for the family and all of us
let me say this so you're clear if there
is conviction
in the federal trial and he
is convicted and the other three
that federal time can run after
the 22 and a half years amen does not
have to run concurrent
which is why we're saying that we still
want
full justice secondly
when we talk about the george floyd
justice and policing act
we know the difference sent it
between two slices of bread and a
sandwich
a sandwich has meat between the two
slices of bread
don't come down with a compromise that
is two
slices of bread with no meat in the
middle
don't put george floyd's name a strong
man
on a weak bill make sure
that you talk to those in the family and
those of us
involved in this struggle before you
make any compromise
the difference between a compromise and
a sellout
is in the eye of the appraiser right we
will
be part of the appraisal questions
june attorney general ellison issued a
clarion call
for the arts and entertainment community
to
take the mantle in seeking justice
any one of the family members can answer
why that might be important to them or
why
it may not right to get an
artist entertainment bar uh
colonists will attempt to answer your
question but we want to
invite other families who are here who
have lost loved ones
uh due to police brutality to also come
forward
uh mr floyd can you answer that question
[Music]
um
we may answer that question on the side
for you
okay okay question about the case
and and attorney staff where are the
other families
today in court derek shovin
offered condolences to the families i
was wondering what would be hard about
that
and also derrick schok's mother
[Music]
continued to say that her son was
innocent and that people did not
know her sound like the family man
and i was wondering what you thought
about those comments the condolences
from derrick shoven and the mother
saying that her son was innocent
and people did not know eric shovin like
her family
all right i just thought about it it's
the same thing with my brother
uh people didn't know who my brother was
they they labeled him the trial was all
about my brother instead
it should have been about mr chauvin so
the
things that she spoke about i understand
that because that's her son
same way she spoke up for her son i
spoke up for my brother
so we all we all love our loved ones
but the fact that i will never see my
brother again
is is worse because she still will have
the opportunity
to see her son in the sale anytime she
wants to that's right
let me say something about that with
philones
when i heard his mother speak okay and i
respect any mother
stand up for their son but it reminded
me and i said it in the eulogy right
here
that george called for his mother
and the one that seemed not to
understand the bond between a mother and
son
when a son would call for his mother
that was no longer alive
was not the floyd family it was her son
derek
because that did not make him stop when
he heard a man call for his mother
i respect his mother he did not respect
george calling for his mother okay and
thank you rev we we want to acknowledge
bishop hardin
who is over the salvation army where
george worked
and uh george did so much great so let's
acknowledge and give him a round of
applause
for the great work they do now we're
going to turn it over
to a lady who needs no introduction
here in minneapolis minnesota at all
she's a
lawyer she's an activist and she's a
freedom
fighter y'all give it up for my sister
nakima
[Applause]
good afternoon it's it's our honor to
stand here with the family of george
floyd
and the lawyers who continue to
represent this family
in their continued pursuit of justice
this is
one step towards progress but this is
not justice and this
is not full accountability as the family
has asked for
i'm nakima levy armstrong i'm a civil
rights attorney based here in
minneapolis
and i'm standing next to tashira garaway
who is part of family supporting
families against police violence
jaylani hussein from care minnesota and
michelle gross
from communities united against police
brutality and we are all here
as people who stand on the front lines
with the folks who are here from the
twin cities
who hold it down time and time again we
gotta give it up
tear gas arrests and demonization
for standing up for george floyd in all
stolen lives
this incident today
of derek chauvin being sentenced
is something that we've been waiting for
for a long time
the sad part about his sentence is that
we know
that black men often receive more time
for doing less
than what derek chovin did there are
plenty of
black men and latino men in prison
for non-violent drug offenses but here
we have a veteran officer
who was literally able to lynch someone
in broad daylight
in the presence of children and other
witnesses
and essentially get a proverbial slap on
the wrist
that is not acceptable judge cahill
should have held him accountable
to the fullest extent of the law it is
not enough that he has received the most
time
compared to other police officers who
have killed people
this is a new
[Laughter]
just because it's the most times
[Laughter]
so
so
so
we need the vaccine of justice in this
country
against the police are killing us
against the economic justice that's
happening in our neighborhoods
we demand justice and we say every
single day that we will demand
justice by any means necessary
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is michelle gross m-i-c-h-e-l
g-r-o-s-s and i am um one of the
founders and currently the president of
the organization
communities united against police
brutality
to say that we are disappointed in this
sentence is an understatement
there were so many aggravating factors
and virtually no mitigating factors the
judge
should have sentenced mr showman to the
fullest extent of the law
he needed to send a message and
his message was lukewarm and best
as the sentence is a presumptive
sentence it even means that
derek showman will only serve two-thirds
of that sentence
it's simply not enough but more than
that
we have had in this state over 270
people
killed at the hands of police in the
state of minnesota
since the year 2000.
derek showman is only one of two
officers who was ever convicted in
sentence
of anything he's one of only four
officers
who has been prosecuted
in other words we have a very very very
bad way to go
to even pretend that we are going to
give justice
we need to reopen all of the cases
at the hands of law enforcement all of
those cases
need to be reopened need to get a
legitimate investigation not a phony
cover-up
as the bureau of criminal apprehension
and these other police agencies have
often done we need to
have an independent investigation and an
independent prosecution
and until we have those things we have
no justice
for these stolen lives but beyond that
we need to change the conditions that
led to these
deaths in the first place we need to
change those conditions
we can honestly say that in the state of
minnesota
and in the city of minneapolis we have
not had
one meaningful change that has occurred
since the death of george floyd that
would prevent it from happening again
that is simply unacceptable
it means that we will continue to go
through this cycle
and families will continue to breathe
and our communities will continue to be
traumatized
over and over and over again because we
refuse to address the underlying problem
this is unacceptable we are not going to
go along with it we demand change and we
demand it now
thank you
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
no doubt no doubt uh we're very
disappointed
uh by the verdict today uh we
we believe that he should oh my name is
prayer cruz i'm lead organizer with bll
minnesota
t-r-a-h-e-r
uh we're very disappointed in the
verdict today we feel
that uh we know that derek chavez should
have been sitting for 30 or 40 years
we know in the state of minnesota people
have been sitting for 30 or 40 years for
non-violent offenses
like selling drugs and things like that
so
if we can send people to jail for 30 40
50 years
for selling drugs or for non-violent
offenses that derek chavez should go
to jail for 30 40 50 years for torturing
somebody for 10 minutes in front of
children
in south side minneapolis um
also like some of the speakers said for
this to be the poem
of where george floyd happened and no
meaningful reform has taken place like
requiring police officers to carry
personal professional liability
insurance
and then qualified immunity having a
database of killer cops
these are some initiatives that could be
put in place right now
that could uh prevent another george
floyd from happening
and at the federal level we don't have a
lynching
anti-lynching bill yet needs to be
passed
since emmett till we haven't had the
george floyd act hasn't been passed
the eric garner act hasn't been passed
so we urge
congress and the senate and president
biden to make some meaningful
legislation about police accountability
and economic justice
thank you
[Applause]
we are someone that has met with our
family
for over a year and a half now almost
two years
hearing from our stories hearing from
our pain
hearing from everything that we have
gone through with
with illusion the people that we love
and he sat down
and heard from us from over a a period
of time
and wrote up legislation on behalf of
our families that we are now
fighting for and uh we will call forward
john mccollum
hello my name is jonathan mcclellan i'm
president of the minnesota justice
coalition
we are part of a collective of
organizations that work with the
families and community to draft and
advance legislation
and other policy initiatives at the
state capitol here in saint paul and in
washington d.c
i want to give my deepest condolences to
the families who should not have to be
here
and whose lives have been changed
forever it has been 65 days since the
derek shaw then a former minneapolis
police officer was found guilty
of second and third degree murder and
second degree manslaughter
shavin who has never expressed remorse
for george floyd's death
even after the verdict was reached on
april 20th 2021
derek shavin violated the public trust
and showed a blatant disregard for human
life
the results of his brutality have caused
immense damage to our community
primarily of color
further this incident has sparked
outrage around the world
we welcome the sentence of 22 and a half
years but feel it did not reach far
enough
derek shavin should be serving life
without the possibility of parole
we would have not had this verdict have
the people not hit the streets demanding
justice
if there wasn't the outpouring of brief
from the world
if there wasn't a brave young girl who
recorded the viral video of george
boyd's death
i asked myself is this what it takes to
get justice for a person of color
is this really justice sure we have a
guilty verdict
sure we have a settlement but will
things actually change not just for the
president
for the present but our future this
conviction is a drop in the bucket of
what the criminal justice system owes
our community
sadly this will be only the second time
in modern
minnesota history that an officer has
been sent to prison for murdering a
human being
on the job absent any substantive change
in legislative policy
has anything really changed how long
before we're right back here fighting
for the justice for another victim of
the police
we know their blueprint murder lies
stall attack the reputation of the
victim cover-up
and repeat we are the state that has
failed to correct the wrongs of the past
and the wounds it has inflicted on
communities of color through
state-sanctioned violence
we must continue to carry this fight
into the legislature
and congress we must change and
dismantle the systems that allow
and have allowed the derek chavins to
thrive behind
the coded slogan of protect and serve we
demand
transparency accountability and justice
for all stolen lives
even the ones not caught on camera our
greatest failures to do nothing knowing
what we know
we must wrap arms around these families
this conviction
and sentencing has a special impact on
these families
who are still fighting for justice for
their loved one
and can only dream of a trial let alone
a sentencing of a killer
so while we fight for change in the
legislature and in congress with policy
we ask that you not forget what was
revealed behind the veil
we ask that you not forget the pain of
these families
we ask that you not forget our humanity
thank you
i'm bishop harding smith a friend of
george floyd
and uh you know history
when we look at history history is
recorded
event of the past
his story but have you heard our story
listen we as a people have been
struggling
for over 400 years
[Music]
you hear of a grind but do you feel of a
pain
50 years from now this family will show
me enduring
the pain and suffering of losing a loved
one
america we are at a crossroads
we are here today to make a decision
on where we go right we need a strong
verdict
this country this nation has a long
history
with racism we need to start
looking deep within ourselves as a
nation
what direction we choose to go
because we as a people will always keep
fighting
we are not going to sit down or lay down
we got to continue to fight for our
rights
today i wish that we had a 40-year
sentence i wish that shulman was also
charged
with hate crimes but that didn't happen
that did not happen and we are really
disappointed
but we also have a cloud coming up in
2022
of alexander kane up to town
of lane and we need to let our voices be
heard
we need to be out here
i thank you all
minnesota mississippi
what's your name that's coming
uh good evening my name is deborah watts
i'm the co-founder of the emmett till
legacy foundation
and a cousin of emmett hill our great
grandfathers were brothers and so they
have a half
smile today because we're not quite
done minnesota mississippi
mississippi repeat after me mississippi
the past is not passed until justice is
served because as we stand here
we cannot ignore the past because 66
years ago
emmett till was murdered in money
mississippi
the murders were acquitted and there's
one last
living accomplice that has never been
charged
her name is carolyn bryant
donna carolyn bryant
donna don't forget that
emmitt's case is in the hands of the
mississippi d.a
dwayne richardson
dwayne richardson also
it is in the hands of the federal
department of justice as well
but i stand here today because i don't
want these families
to have the same 66 year journey
that we have right now so my sympathy my
condolences
go out to the floyd family and all of
these families that behind me that are
behind me
we need justice if you want to talk
about reconciliation
spell j u s
[Music]
i am not here for white guilt
i am not here for listening to
kumbaya i'm here to make a difference
and these families through their pain
and their passion
and their purposes are not activists
none of us
are activists but we are activated
activated to move forward towards
justice so just
remember emmett till if you don't hear
the parallels or see the parallels then
there's some blindness happening
but some of the same things that happen
in mississippi
they just wear different uniforms right
different uniforms so the same cultural
biases and racism and white supremacy is
just by another name
new narrative so emmett till
justice still needs to be served hr 55
which is the anti-lynching bill
h.f 2586 is the
emmett lewis tale victims recovery
program to give
support to these families because
they're beyond some of the stature of
limitations
for help and support so i just say thank
you for your attention
thank you for these families being
activated
and speaking your truths so the past
is not passed until justice is
significant served of george floyd
courtney ross
and also uh dj with twin cities
coalition justice for jamal all right
um my name is courtney ross
i'm the fiancee of george boyd
on earth and in heaven you will always
be mine you'll always be the love of my
life
i want to say one thing today
i want to speak to the people of
minneapolis this is my home
i'm 612 for life
this is where i plan to be forever i'm
not calling
for an evening of peace but i am calling
for an evening of non-violence if you
are using floyd's name in any way
to promote that that is not what he was
about
if you knew him he was about peace love
inclusiveness and helping people if he
saw anything going on
that was that caused violence or was
hurting someone he would take
his six feet long arms out and try and
stop them
and then pray with them to make sure
that they could go on with the better
day
and not act out in the devil's way so
again
i pray i pray minneapolis
that we have a non-violent evening
you can still fight come with us
come with dj come with family supporting
families against police violence
come join us anytime get your screams
out get your anger out in that way
and visit the capitol get your anger out
that
people
a man that means so much to me
who has been boots on the ground since
this happened over
an employee's name and made changes and
without him and all the people that you
know i'm speaking to today
it wouldn't even happen today
[Applause]
my name is um hooker i ordered i helped
organize with uh tcc for jay
um i'm going to say this is an
unfortunate day
it's a day that shows that white tears
still outweigh justice
it's a day where the government
continues to reaffirm
white supremacy people can go to jail
for selling drugs
in the state for 30 to 40 years
in other states where it's legal and he
got 22 and a half years
we have not seen any change on the local
level
with the city council giving more money
to these killer cops
we haven't seen any change at the state
level with the senate playing games all
session and continuing
to play games during this special um
special session and at the federal level
where they prioritize where it's
democratizing
stopping the genocide that's happening
here in america to black and native
bodies
they'd rather help brought another
genocide around the world against the
palestinians
i have a question for y'all today
what does change look like
does the la e does that look like change
listen
does change look like dante wright
does change look like winston smith
is that what justice is about
i expect people to stay out in these
streets and to stay activated and we
still got three
more to go and we still should turn this
verdict over and we should get more
years so
all prayers to the people
we have a few more speakers and then we
will conclude this press conference
we will now call up donnie williams the
grandfather of brian quinone
all right johnny brian quinone has
married my granddaughter ashley
and in september 7th of
2019 he was murdered
by richfield and he dined at police
this is not a minneapolis issue lisa
derek shoving was a minneapolis cop
these other three guys are minneapolis
cops
this happens outside of minneapolis
this happens in ridgefield in edina
this happens in brooklyn center in
brooklyn park
it happens in eagan it happens in
bloomington
the department of justice is here to
investigate
the mpd the mpd
is under the sculpture of hennepin
county
which therefore should be investigated
as well
yeah that's hard who files
charges when you get in trouble and who
doesn't
file charges against police mike freeman
who's the head of the county district
attorney
[Music]
i hope the doj does the right thing
but they need to take this scope and
practices and patterns and whatever
investigation they have
and expand it outside of minneapolis
go to saint paul this is a dangerous
police department in the state
go to the bca
go to these people that cover this crap
up and protect their brethren
with laws on the bullets we try to get
things changed qualified immunity is a
freaking joke
unless you're a cop gives you impunity
gives you what you can do
because you know your back is covered
nobody else has it
brian quinones was killed before
george floyd i've marched the streets
for a year
plus screaming george floyd's name
22 and a half years is a freaking joke
we all agree we know it he deserved more
this kid deserves something
that kid deserves something call me
eisler deserves something
and every time one someone else gets
killed
these kids move down a list [ __ ]
yeah i'm sorry
all right the list grows
and gets new names added to it i'm going
to tell you
the new names are important but
this kid's more important
and i don't want anybody to ever forget
this kid
hey i don't want anybody to forget
travis jordan
or kobe heisler or philando castile
or tamara clark they're on the list yes
they're not fresh in your news or in
your face but they're
just as important until some of us are
more important
thank you thank you
[Applause]
we will now have the spring of
travis jordan paul
hi i'm paul johnson a friend of travis
jordan who was
also my roommate and living with me who
was killed on november 9
2018 within three minutes and 35 seconds
of being called for a wellness check
people of color are 16 times that's
one six times more likely to be hurt
or murdered on a wellness check
than white folks that's 16 times we
already know that they're 2.5 times more
likely to be killed
than white people in general in general
yet they can have a bad day and that
turns into 16
times that they become what
america has deemed the super predator
we must stop this sort of name calling
it's ridiculous
and absolutely uncalled for travis
jordan was having a bad day
he deserved to get help and our city is
failing people constantly our mayor is
inept
and is absentee at best
[Music]
since his seat is so empty all the time
from doing it
correctly i decided to take this
community
and fill it this november this one paul
johnson will be running for mayor
is running for mayor and we are taking
these families and our voices right to
the seat
we will not be forgotten we have been
quieted we have been swept under the
rock
you try to go on to the next person and
the next person
trying to make everyone appear as though
it was in a vacuum
how many people have to die to
understand
that this is a problem and these are not
singular events
okay we are coming we are making the
change
we are not urging these people to change
anymore
as some have stated we're not urging you
anymore
we are coming and we are making these
changes
gentlemen if you're in your seats and
you're comfortable now
get ready you're leaving bye all power
to the people
[Applause]
we we will have one last speaker and
then we will conclude this press
conference
we will have the father of kobe heisler
jason heisler
thank you
my name is jason heisler the father of
kobe heisler
who was killed during a mental health
crisis he was a 21 year old autistic man
in brooklyn center on august 31st
2019. it's almost been two years
me and these families today met with the
department with merrick carl attorney
general
merrick garland's department of justice
today
because they're in town to conduct
and practice investigation of the
minneapolis police
it's not the first time these police
have been investigated
this investigation is over they have a
culture of racism
a culture of excessive force and a
culture of
murder and
they kill black people and they kill
people who are disabled
they kill 500 people in the last 20
years
and over 50 percent of them were
disabled
my son was an autistic black man and i
met with these families today
and a lot of it has been covered already
but i want to say
if they're investigating the minneapolis
police
i want to tell you that
the culture of excessive force and
murder
doesn't end at 51st avenue north
or 60 seconds south
these other cities have more races on
their police force
so i want them to
conduct a pattern of practices
investigation of all four counties
i want them to have independent
investigators
for all of these families cases
the bca and mike freeman
are in bed with the police and they're
never going to have an independent
investigation of their buddies who they
need to prosecute criminals
i wish i wish derek chovan would go to
jail forever
and he's such a criminal that he
probably would
he will he will this ain't the only
crime he's committed
he claims florida residents make it a
hundred grand a year
he's a criminal and a murderer
sorry about that and
so i want an independent investigator
there's we come out here every night and
people
make a lot of call outs to tell people
to come down but i don't
i only want to call out one person and
it's my buddy keith
ellison he needs to get down here
and investigate every time the police
kill someone
because we can't trust mike freeman and
the bca just re-iterates
lies
do any of you guys have any questions
for the for any of us
thank you from hearing from all of our
families the people that support us
thank you for being here today
[Music]
we have we will be continuing on
uh we will be marching in the streets uh
the families that have lost loved ones
at the hands of police as well as uh
some of our strong supporters will be
marching
right after this and then we also have
action this evening at 9 00 pm we will
also be marching
uh down in the streets as well thank you
can you end us the way you usually do
[Music]
okay
i would just like to say that
our families our families are just going
through so much
right now sitting here watching
these people slightly
give george floyd justice and knowing
that this is something that we're hoping
and pleading for
we're pleading and and crying out
that hopefully one day our loved ones
will be valued enough to receive the
same amount of justice
but until then we will not be quiet
and we will stand up with our lives on
the line
we will stand up even when they try to
silence
us even when they try to shut us out
even when they try to cover up our
murders
we will continue on because we don't
have a choice
we don't have a choice i don't have a
choice
because i have a 15 year old son named
justin junior
kobe eisler's father doesn't have a
choice
brian quinone as family doesn't have a
choice and all the rest of these
families that are out here do not have a
choice
but to continue on so even though we may
get scared or afraid or discouraged at
times
we don't have a choice but to keep
fighting even though
we may not even be close to having a
trial
we don't have a choice but to keep
fighting because there is a life
that deserves to live and did not
deserve to die like that
none of them and we will be fighting
that these officers be held accountable
just like garrett charlotte
[Music]
we must love and support one another we
must love and support one another
we
[Music]
[Applause]
we must love and support one another we
must love and support one another
we have nothing to lose but our change
we have nothing to lose
we have nothing to lose
[Applause]
oh
right now they're trying to cover it up
and we're trying to stop them from
covering it up
so we got to put the pressure on the bca
on the governor who oversees the bca
we got to keep putting the pressure on
these people because they're actively
trying to cover up a murder in our faces
yes we we had a meeting um all of us
uh our coalition earlier this week
we had a meeting and we are asking for
the doj
to step into this investigation because
we know that the bca is not going to do
the right thing in investigating we also
truly
know in our hearts that there were
cameras out there that day
that uh there's no way in uptown that
there was just no business cameras or
anything
that caught this footage so they're down
to the point where
they're no longer you know with george
floyd and went uh live
and spread everywhere so now they're
just to the point well
we're just gonna tell them that there
was no videos there was nothing
and then just covered up and everybody
just needs to move on
so but we are trying to fight for the
doj to uh
go into their go into that case and
investigate
and to fire ramona domit as well that's
right
my reaction to the essential scene today
is that
we got uh a little we got the crumbs
that they always give us
you know with this sentencing but this
officer did get put away
now we got many more officers that need
to be put away
because like i said earlier we know that
uh george floyd was the face of hundreds
of murders here in the state of
minnesota
and but we also know that just like
george floyd was the face
of hundreds of murders bearing charvin
is the face of hundreds of killer cops
that are enrollment in our community and
serving on our forces
we want the same amount of justice we
deserve our families deserve
the same amount of justice as as george
floyd
and anyone else and we will not be quiet
until
we receive that thank you
i know all the press is gonna join us
for the march too
so we'll see you on the street around
the world
thank you
thank you
you